let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
good afternoon everybody
welcome to let's talk the
tony michaels podcast
we got a ton of stuff to talk about
today
[Music]
but let me
start by asking
everyone if they still own a mr potato
and dr seuss books because apparently
everyone in the country is canceling dr
seuss and canceling mr potato
this is the narrative this is the
[ __ ]
dr seuss they're canceling dr seuss
oh there's no more mr potato head
and we're going to get to why this is
relevant because
they can't get off this whole canceled
culture
whatever the hell they're talking about
no one canceled mr potato
number one who gives a [ __ ] who gives a
flying
[ __ ] about a [ __ ] mr potato
number one that the goddamn potato
doesn't have genitalia
it never had genitalia and frankly in
the beginning the mr
the mr potato toy didn't even have a
potato in the [ __ ] box there was no
plastic potato
you actually had to use one of your
[ __ ] potatoes they had your house
and you stuck the [ __ ] eyes and the
mustache on the goddamn thing
and it stunk and it was nasty and
everyone's like this is dumb this is
gross
so that's when they made the plaster
potato and the plastic potato
never had genitalia it never had
genitalia never
and they just called it miss potato
because they had a [ __ ] mustache and
then they made a
mrs potato because there's a mr and a
missus
but who gives a [ __ ] if they take the
mister off the box
this is all pr stunt by hasbro by the
way
to sell more potato heads
because they said oh we're getting rid
of mr potato no more mr potato and
people lose their [ __ ] minds
on twitter and they lose their [ __ ]
minds on the internet
and maybe it's it's it's the right wing
they're like you can't cancel
what's that toy called again mr mr oh
yeah mr potato i remember that you can't
cancel that toy
like i thought we'd cancel this because
that toy sucked
i mean no one gives a [ __ ] who mr potato
is unless you watch
toy story that's the only significance
is the character mr and mr potato head
in toy story other than that no one
gives a [ __ ] about that toy
nobody and hasbro's like hmm
how can we sell more potato heads
well we got all these potato heads on
the shelf you know what we could do
we could just say we're canceling mr
potato head people would lose their
[ __ ] minds
and then what we could do about an hour
later is say no no no no no no we're not
getting rid of mr and mrs potato head
we're just getting rid of the gender box
that's all they did people they just
took mister off the box
and said potato head and they got all
the [ __ ] in there
mr misses it's all in the [ __ ] box
it's like this dr seuss [ __ ]
oh my oh my god canceling dr seuss
really that's that's
that's the big concern that the right
wing has is canceling dr seuss
where the [ __ ] were they when people
were were boycotting the lorax
you remember this the movie the lorax
came out
they did a movie on the book dr seuss's
book
dr seuss's book the lorax
which is a [ __ ] book about being
environmentally responsible not cutting
down all the [ __ ] trees so you still
have some
which is a decent [ __ ] message hello
but the christian and the right wing
were like oh this is
liberal agenda has liberal agenda
written all over it
canceled boycott you
[ __ ] radicals and they they boycotted
the lorax which is fine [ __ ] them they
don't want to watch a good movie they
don't have to that's a good [ __ ]
movie
it's a good movie it's got good music in
it it's a good [ __ ] movie
there's a couple books that dr seuss
wrote
years ago that did not have 2021
context in it and those books should or
should
not be read to certain children or all
children and people should be able to
make that [ __ ] decision
a rationaled adult should make a
decision whether they should read a
certain book
to their kids or not i mean most people
don't show playboys to their kids
but no one's cancelling playboy
this is ridiculous it's all this thing
where oh my god it's cancel
cause they don't want to get cancelled
because their ideas [ __ ] suck
their ideas are [ __ ] horrible
horrible [ __ ] ideas terrible policy
none of it makes sense no one wants it
it's [ __ ]
it's a big pile of [ __ ] [ __ ] and
garbage
i mean jesus christ there wasn't one
goddamn republican
who voted for the corona corona release
relief package in the house
not [ __ ] one of them and it doesn't
look like there's a goddamn one of them
that are going to vote for it in the
senate
not one of them think about how popular
the corona
coronavirus relief package is and not
one of them
not [ __ ] one of them is going to vote
for it
they're cancelling the coronavirus
relief package
they're canceling it cancel culture
give me a [ __ ] break cancel culture
my ass
dumb and then they had a whole goddamn
event
a whole [ __ ] event last weekend
c pack q pack
in pack as i called it
in one of my videos this week in nazi
in for nazi we're going to play a club a
couple clips here
uh the videos that i made for cpac i
would have a little bit of [ __ ] to talk
about
because there's plenty to unpack from
cpac but the one thing
the one thing that is most significant
about cpac
well there's two really but the one is
the most significant unsignificant thing
the most significant thing is that
republicans are hell-bent
on keeping the narrative of election
fraud alive so they can suppress
our vote that's the goal
they don't give a [ __ ] about trump they
don't give a [ __ ] about him
all's the republican politicians want to
do is they want trump
to carry the water of voter suppression
and the bucket is election fraud
and a stolen election because if they
can convince
enough people and enough states
that the election was stolen and that it
was all
fraud then they can pass more and more
laws to keep
people from voting and the reason why
they would do that
is because more people vote
the less they win
the more people that vote the less they
win
because their ideas suck and
they know that we know that they know
that their [ __ ] ideas suck i mean
what what is their policy position
anymore
what is it did you if you listened to
cpac at
all they didn't come up with one good
policy idea that sounded like that
sounds like it they didn't talk about
debt and deficit at all hardly
it was all cancer culture they're trying
to cancel us
and it was and it was voter
supreme voter voter fraud dead people
voting
voting machines were rigged on and on
and on the [ __ ] went
the other most significant insignificant
thing
is trump it's trump
it was very clear very clear that these
boneheads
are all in for these dummies
all in for this trumper [ __ ]
because they want they want him to carry
the water
for voter suppression because he's
willing to do it
he's willing to do it and they're
willing to worship at the altar of trump
to have it so much so that they hauled
in a [ __ ]
a golden idol a false idol a golden calf
i did a video about it maybe you've seen
it maybe you didn't
but if you didn't it's time to watch it
so let's let's go to that video about
the golden idol and then we'll talk
about
the golden idol on the other side the
golden calf
let's talk republicans throw their thin
veiled clan rally this weekend
disguising it as
cpac these are the circus spending most
of their time worshiping at the altar of
their orange
deity thing so far is to actually roll
in a golden idol that resembles that fat
[ __ ] slob
it's almost like there should be a
sacred book that these christians could
look to
with some text on things like you know
false idols and [ __ ]
luck getting them to read a [ __ ] book
jesus
[ __ ] christ republican party i got a
piece of [ __ ] advice for you
when it comes to this christianity stuff
you might want to [ __ ] or get off the
pot
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] or get off the pot and it's true
uh you know enough is enough of this you
know moral high ground
[ __ ] they've got the moral high ground
uh they're the ones that can speak to
the rest of america about
what moral christian values are give me
a [ __ ] break
cheering cheering uh a golden a really
tacky golden statue by the way
not even a good looking one i mean that
the guy had
the [ __ ] american flag swimming
trunks on with flip-flops this guy's
never had a pair of swimming trunks on
in his life
give me a break give me a [ __ ] break
and then what was the magic wand in his
hand did you guys notice that that was i
thought
what the what's the magic wand and the
guy who made this thing apparently this
thing was plastic just painted up as
gold
which is totally appropriate for trump
a plastic [ __ ] statue that's painted
gold
it's not real gold it's [ __ ] fake
gold
of course it was of course it was and
then there's pictures of people
oh look look we love our god we love our
jesus donald trump
worshiping it bowing down at it holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but i'm sick of being lectured by these
people talking about how they have the
moral high ground
and the christians are the ones who are
gonna tell us what and when and where to
do and how they're the they're
they're the ones that are the real
americans give me a [ __ ] break
you need to go read your goddamn book
for about 10 minutes just read that just
read that
that little part about the ten
commandments
and read the second one there about gods
before you
and false idols you dumb [ __ ]
so then we move on uh from
from the uh american idol to
and i want to talk about this for a
minute here because
uh there was a lot of debate
about the nazi symbol
that was seemed like it was used as the
stage
and uh you know maybe i'll just play the
video on this and
talk about the the nazi stage
on the other side of the clip stage
right wing
let's talk at n pack this weekend
you know and for nazi they fall just
short of making the swastika the shape
of their stage
we can debate the intent of the
symbolism here but do we really believe
that these right-wing political theater
nuts
didn't think this [ __ ] through or no
swastika what shape are we going with
maybe we shouldn't go with the swastika
okay okay okay we'll swatch a collide
that'll do republican party you claim
not to be a nazi
but you look like one if the swastika
fits
[ __ ] them so
so it's not
it's not a swastika the stage was not a
swastika
and i forget what the [ __ ] symbol is
and and it really
doesn't even matter what the name of the
symbol is
what really matters is what the
significance of what that symbol looks
like of what it was
uh if they used that symbol for a lot of
hitler youth
uh propaganda and uniforms but more
importantly they used it on the ss
uniforms that symbol
which rather they want to claim that it
was intentional
or not or that was the case it doesn't
[ __ ] matter that's what it looks like
that's what it looks like and really
honestly if anyone believes that
a design is not intentional you are
[ __ ] dumb design is intention that's
the whole point of design in the first
place
rather rather the design is is is
politically motivated
or it's artistically motivated or it's
structurally or architecturally
motivated
design is intent that's the whole
point is that there is intent behind
design
so this idea that they had no intent
behind their design is
[ __ ] dumb they had intent behind
their design now rather that intent was
to have a nazi symbol on the stage or
not
well that's the [ __ ] question that we
got
and i guess it depends on who did the
design
because every no one threw their hand up
saying i was me
it was me i came up with that design let
me show you the drawings that i had
let me show you the concepts that i
scratched off on a napkin
nobody nobody match slap you know gave
the
the [ __ ] boilerplate plate oh there
was no intention and it's offensive to
say that there was intention that this
was a nazi symbol
well if if if you have to make a
statement
at a [ __ ] quasi-clan rally at a
neo-nazi convention
when you're trying to compete with the
with the afpak
the america first pack which is which
was a bunch of white supremacist
neo-nazis
you know giving each other verbal blow
jobs
just down the street when you're trying
to compete with that
you might want a stage that neo-nazis
and white supremacists will appreciate
that's all i'm saying [ __ ]
me a break of course there was intention
behind the design
now rather the actual intention was to
have a nazi symbol
inside the cpac that's a good question
and i don't even know that the question
needs to be asked
because here's the thing everyone saw it
even the white supremacists and
neo-nazis saw it
and we didn't hear a lot from them did
we
weighing in on how that wasn't a white
supremacist or a nazi symbol
as they scratched it off their armband
[ __ ]
you they know what the symbol is
they know what it means they know the
significance of it
and they noticed it that it was there
mission accomplished mission
accomplished
but you know what more than anything
because i believe sunlight is the best
disinfectant you guys know this
i don't i don't think we should be uh uh
not letting trump speak in front of a
microphone i actually think uh it would
benefit this country if he got
out in front of a microphone every
goddamn day and said the same goddamn
two-bit [ __ ]
speech that he gave old hat [ __ ]
just the same old [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
actually did a video on it ah what do
you think
same old [ __ ] he could the only thing
new really the only thing new because i
listened to the entire trump speech
which was difficult because it's the
same [ __ ] that he's been saying for the
last [ __ ] four years that any
and any event that he was at he was
speaking and he'd say the
same goddamn [ __ ] he'd go through the
same goddamn
verbal diarrhea because that's what it
is he never he never actually held on to
a certain idea or had a certain way that
he would walk through a speech he was
all over the [ __ ] map
all over the [ __ ] map saying phrases
you know just china china
election fraud election fraud emails
emails joe biden biden election fraud i
mean just all over the map
but the one thing that was significant
about the speech
and i'm gonna play my my video and we'll
talk about some more stuff on the other
side about the
about the speech because i was i was
live tweeting it the entire time i was
live commentating it i should say
but uh the one thing significant about
the speech
that was a change in what he had said
before in other speeches
was he talked about women's sports uh he
really danced around
the subject i thought i i thought he
could have been a much better bigot
on this subject he could have went way
further and he didn't
uh but he danced around the subject
because he really has danced around the
subject the entire time he's been
president
uh he really did a lot of a lot of bad
stuff
uh for uh the lgbtq plus community
uh you know the one significant thing
that joe biden has turned around
was the transgender uh ban
on military personnel which is [ __ ]
ridiculous
uh in in so many ways number one if
you're an able-bodied person it
shouldn't matter what the
what the hell genitalia you were born
with and what genitalia you have now
it should not [ __ ] matter if you are
an able-bodied person to do a job in the
military or the government
that you should be able to do that
[ __ ] job we
we we all are humans every [ __ ] one
of us
it doesn't matter what [ __ ] you know
penis or [ __ ] you got your pants it
doesn't matter
your genitalia does not matter it does
not if you are
able to do a job do it do it
but the fact the fact that doc that that
donald trump banned it and and that joe
biden had to
undo a ban of human beings
being in the military because of who
they were when they born and who they
were now
because you know that's they gotta catch
on sound familiar
jim jordan booger sugar junior
to prevent an able-bodied person to be a
military personnel is [ __ ] ridiculous
it's it's inhumane
it's indecent and it needs to be stopped
but when joe biden
signed to repeal
uh donald trump's ban of
trans people being able-bodied trans
people being in the military and being
military personnel
and holding those positions when joe
biden banned it
we we shouldn't have to cheer that
should be like yeah that's a decent
thing to do that's what we should be
doing
that's what we should be doing it's the
same things as 15 an hour we should be
doing that we
if we get it we shouldn't have to cheer
that we get it it'd be like well we
actually should have a lot more but
you know we shouldn't just be treating
trans people as decent people in the
military we should be treating decent
people just in general
and [ __ ] general okay
let's let's go with the no
discrimination uh
uh uh uh stance on this
that was the most significant change
in his same old [ __ ] speech that he gave
was was the thing about and he took the
he took the
he took the the little the little nick
of
oh women are going to be in danger
because
trans women are in trans or in women's
sports and you know basically act like
you know
a trans woman was going to pick pick a
woman up and you know snap her in half
or
i don't know what the hell but but but
the the thing that uh
that was significant about the speech
and and his his
his language and he was very careful it
was written out you could tell it
because he could barely read it
uh biological male biological male is
the words that he used
and that was what was written on the
teleprompter
in quotes i'm sure uh because he had he
struggled with the word biological
biological male that's what he called it
that's what he
said it's ridiculous
he could he couldn't even muster the
[ __ ] courage to call him trans women
piece of [ __ ] and it goes back to the
sign that marjorie taylor green had uh
and i i believe that's why it was in the
speech
was to stoke that [ __ ] that she did
the week before
that vile piece of garbage but
let's play my video about about donald
trump's speech
and then we'll finish up with his speech
on the other side
because i also i also today want to get
to
uh the insurrection january 6
hearings that are going on in the senate
right now yesterday
uh i i thought yesterday was actually
more significant
seeing how the senators act and today
was pretty significant because we found
out some stuff about the national guard
so i want to get to that stuff but let's
watch the donald trump
same old [ __ ] let's talk oh tonight
donald trump walked out on the cpac
swastika stage and proceeds with his big
lie
mouth diarrhea jesus [ __ ] christ this
is the
same old five year worn out bit this
dumb [ __ ]
he did hit all the keyword trumpy
talking points though
oh weak ass arguments like socialism
aina ten attended china china
election frau russia russia russia
russia you see a pattern
there is one thing that is abundantly
clear joe
biden lives rent free inside this
motherfucker's skull
i mean he's taking up the whole space
that obama and hillary had on lease
even the [ __ ] loft apartment inside
this dumb [ __ ] spring that rosie
o'donnell had occupied for [ __ ] years
biden's got that [ __ ] too when it
finally came to the part where he was
gonna announce a run in 2024
well he [ __ ] pussed out i guess the
manga queuing on [ __ ]
they'll be disappointed [ __ ] them
so so there's a lot to unpack about uh
donald trump's speech uh as far as the
joe biden component because joe biden
obviously
uh did this joe biden beating him
um and him having to trudge out over and
over and over
that the the election was stolen and
it's it's it's very obvious that it
wasn't
it bothers the complete [ __ ] out of him
i
i actually think as as far as joe biden
is concerned he's
he's much more on donald trump [ __ ] list
than barack obama could ever be which
i'm sure joe biden um is not paying much
attention but if i were joe biden that
would excite the hell out of me
because if donald trump is mad at me now
we're in good
shape we're in good shape but
i mean uh he focused a lot of his speech
on joe biden
uh and and basically how how bad a job
joe biden's done which
is not even not even close to the truth
he trudged out the whole gas price thing
and milk prices and then he proceeded
then he proceeded to brag about how
great farmers are doing
so on one hand on one hand joe biden
is the worst thing in the country's you
know going in the ditch
and on the other hand the farmers are
doing great they're doing great they're
doing better than they ever have before
because of him wait a second wait a
second
if the gas if the farmers are doing so
well because of you
then the gas prices must because of you
they can't be because of joe biden but
wait wait wait wait wait
if the gas prices are joe biden's fault
well then the farmer's doing great that
that must be joe biden's
fault too so you see where i'm going
with this
this is this is this is old hat
republican stuff
they want to take credit for the stuff
that's going their way
and they don't want to take the blame
for the [ __ ] that ain't going their way
and then the what about ism oh my god
the
what about ism well what about this what
about that
well what about this oh what about that
and that's basically uh moving on to the
insurrection hearings that we've been
having
the last few days because i think i
think as far as news goes cpac was very
significant
but the most significant thing on a cpac
that that the lesson that we're going to
learn over the next 24 months of what
these republicans
are are that what their what their
strategy is is to suppress the vote
that is their goal and and and they're
using
they're using donald trump carrying the
water of election fraud
uh in the in the stolen election bucket
they're using that as their way to
suppress the vote because let's face it
folks if we all go out and vote based on
their policies
and vote based on the what they want for
this country they are not going to get
voted back in
they are not going to win the house they
are not going to win the senate the only
way for them to win those
those chambers back is to number one
gerrymander the vote which they're gonna
do they've been doing it they'll always
do it unless we stop it
and number two the second thing that
they're going to try to do
is pass state laws to keep black and
brown people from voting
pretty simple that's their strategy
that's it their strategy is to keep
black and brown people from voting
and young people and
gerrymander and maybe they'll get the
house back possibly the senate but
senator state races so they really gotta
do the whole voter suppression thing
and there is 20 i believe 22
22 republican senators up for
re-election
22 of them in 2022 very
very very very maybe q anon could
do the math and you know carry the one
and we could have some sort of [ __ ]
conspiracy theory there
speaking of conspiracy theories let's
talk about
march 4th and why march 4th is
significant
of the january 6 insurrection hearings
it's the same [ __ ] now i
i got asked today on the phone
what i thought would happen on march 4th
uh because there there are some reports
today
uh about march 4th that of course this
this is all
to kind of bring you up the speed of
what march 4th is
this is all the q anon soup and i call
it q anon soup because they take
all these different conspiracy theories
and they mix them all in a pot and they
stir them around to make a soup
because this part of the q anon
conspiracy theory did not show up
until until donald trump was not
inaugurated on january 20th
so they believed that the state
legislators would overturn
well first they thought the supreme
court would be on their side which it
wasn't
on december 14th they thought that they
were just going to have a
special electors and they'd have their
own slate of electors and elect donald
trump as
president of the united states and they
couldn't even find the electoral college
that didn't work so he stokes them and
stokes them and stokes them for almost a
whole month for january 6
and they decide that mike pence mike
pence
can overturn the election with a stroke
of the pen
or holler of the microphone whatever
which it didn't matter what the hell
happened even if they would have stopped
them from
certifying the vote joe biden still
would have been inaugurated on january
20th
it doesn't it didn't matter if they
certified the vote or not the vote was
the vote
it was done the state certified it they
would have sworn in joe biden
that is just a ceremonial thing that
they do to open the envelope and act
like they're important
congress who would have thought congress
does ceremonial things to act like
they're important
but this boneheaded thing that they
thought that vice president mike pence
was gonna do
he did not have the power to do and even
if he had the power to do it joe biden
would have made sure hillary
clinton would have been the president in
2017
and al gore would have made himself
president in 2000
me a [ __ ] break this is dumb it
doesn't exist
mike pence knew it exists didn't exist
all the republicans including josh
hawley and ted cruz
mo brooks louis gomer marjorie taylor
green
lauren bobert they all knew that it
didn't exist but they didn't give a [ __ ]
they were trying to stoke these people
because donald trump wanted
wanted his supporters to save him
whatever means necessary
and after january 6 didn't happen and
didn't work
they came up with this january 20th that
somehow
donald trump's going to be sworn in on
january 20th the military's going to
come in and arrest everybody and hang
everybody or some [ __ ] i don't know
what the hell they were saying
and then there was a theory that they
were gonna do the face-off thing which i
think was a troll at first
where they were gonna switch donald
trump and joe biden's faces jesus
[ __ ] christ
so when january 20th rolled around and
joe biden was inaugurated president well
that that that part of the soup didn't
taste good anymore just like all the
other parts of the queuing on soup
didn't taste good anymore
so they had to and add more ingredients
into the queuing soup
and that's where this march 4th [ __ ]
comes in
the march 4 stuff comes from
the the the sovereign citizen conspiracy
theory
every conspiracy theory you know there's
the flat earth there's the jfk
there's the sovereign citizen you know
they all had their own little
their own conspiracy theories but q anon
has done something very significant
they're like we don't care what your
conspiracy theory is you're
welcome here so they invite the
sovereign citizen in because sovereign
citizens
believe that the nation is a corporation
it's not
actually a country you're not a citizen
you're a member and you can relinquish
your membership so you don't have to pay
taxes and they can't imprison you all
kinds of stupid [ __ ]
which is not the case and i believe it's
the 10th amendment
that in the 10th amendment it says
incorporated somewhere like the word
incorporated
and they think that made it that country
a corporation which it did not
but it moved the inauguration date from
march 4th to january 20th
and the reason why it moved it is
because we no longer needed that much
time from the election
to the inauguration because of railroads
railroads caused much quicker travel
it didn't take people long that long to
get back to washington
from their election it did not it did
not take that long
so that that's why that that that's why
we just close the gap and i think we
should close the gap even more if this
event
on january 6 does not prove that we need
to close the gap and as soon as the
state certified the results congress
vote on that [ __ ] and the very
next day the president is sworn in
we don't need this [ __ ] where we
wait till after the first the year or
whatever
we do not need to be doing that [ __ ]
we need to inaugurate the president
united states whoever the state
certifies immediately
immediately there's no reason to wait
none
zero reason to wait for a new president
i don't care if it's democrat republican
whoever
we [ __ ] voted for him we [ __ ] won
her
we want that person to be president
inaugurator
inaugurate him do it now don't wait
most democracies that's what they do
so that's where this march 4th thing is
coming in and there's a lot of warnings
today
from law enforcement and security
apparatus
that is saying that there's some
significant uh white supremacist
neo-nazi militant groups
that are that have credible threats
for tomorrow and even into the weekend i
guess i i guess the point is is that
if they don't get their way tomorrow
they'll just extend their their delusion
on into the fifth and the sixth and into
the weekend
and then maybe by sunday they'll be so
[ __ ] drunk and worn out that they'll
just give up
so it's bound to be an entertaining
weekend somewhere in this country
because we're probably gonna see the
trumpers with their flags and their fat
bellies hanging out of their trump
shirts
but that brings us to the
insurrection hearings that we had in
washington
uh yesterday they they
deposed and t in the uh law enforcement
test of they've been testifying for the
last few days
on capitol hill about
the insurrection capitol police
yesterday was the fbi director chris ray
which i think was actually some of the
most telling testimony
um now whether that was good or bad or
there was big news or not big news
i i i think um showing
that the fbi knows more than they know
and they're not telling us
and what looks like uh the senators
know more than what we know and they're
not telling us there's something
significant
because there was never really any kind
of clear-cut answer to
any real question other than you know
[ __ ] back and forth about i mean tom
cotton
tom cotton was he got on this topic of
jihad and
ms-13 and uh went on a tirade about
brown people
black people and you know what let me
play a video on this because
this is very important uh of the context
of this because i actually recorded this
tick tock
on january 7th this was the day after
the insurrection
that i that i recorded this and i
actually said these things
about treason privilege
treason privilege let's talk this is to
all you dumb [ __ ] out there
who are still wondering why black
off peop the holy [ __ ] grail of
evidence on january 6
of white privilege in this country
anyone is [ __ ] confused about what
the [ __ ] i'm talking about
you need to sit down and shut the [ __ ]
up
give you little [ __ ] dose of reality
here at the last black lives matter
rally
the national guard was waiting for those
peaceful protesters
january 6 some of those people that were
supposed to protect that building
let those white people through wasn't
for another two [ __ ] hours
until the national guard
showed up you damn well better bet when
they did show up if it was black people
there
they wouldn't have asked them nicely to
leave pick up america
the world is watching
well i said it back then and then today
we get confirmation that uh apparently
mike flynn's brother
uh was a part of making sure that they
stalled
the national guard which there's a lot
of confusion about this national guard
people keep saying that the mayor of
washington dc has the power to to
initiate and call on the national guard
she does not the the only
the only people that have the power to
call the national guard
are the governors and that's the [ __ ]
purpose of the national guard
that's it that is the militia you dumb
[ __ ] out there clamoring about militia
it's the national guard that is the
actual army that that
that the governors have the ability to
call
to call upon it's the whole point and
and in washington dc
the person who has control over the
national guard in washington dc is the
president of the united states
and at the time on january 6 i believe
the president united states was
uh what was his name kind of a fat
orange slob
oh yeah trump trump had the power to
call the national guard and they
actually had to call
larry hogan of maryland to get
maryland's national guard
that's why it was so late and today we
find out that it was intentionally
stalled
because of optics because of optics of
course it was because of optics
of course it was it was white people
they didn't want to be seen as calling
in the national guard on white people
especially trump and republicans
you [ __ ] break
if those would have been black people
those national guard would have been
surrounding that rally
surrounding the rally
the last time there was a black lives
matter rally in washington dc
there was a whole troop of national
guard standing armed
on the lincoln memorial before
black lives matter even got there
they were waiting for black lives matter
and it ain't because they it ain't
because they're
violent it's because they're black
and the optics that's what this was
about
and they wanted to give those white
people time to go
stop congress you [ __ ] break
and this what about ism this [ __ ]
what about is a blame game
that somehow they're dressed up as
antifa somehow their black lives matter
dressed up as trump supporters
give me a [ __ ] break no one believes
that [ __ ]
we even got confirmation yesterday from
the director of the fbi
that has arrested three over 300 trump
supporters
confirmation
confirmation
that these were trump supporters
and all you have to do is either either
walk down to the detention center
or show up to the house or go to the
probation officer
of the person who has the little
electronic device striped around their
ankle
and these senators can go interview
those people
and find out if their trump supporters
are their antifa or their black lives
matter
it ain't [ __ ] rocket science of
course they were trump supporters
[ __ ] half these people that are being
arrested are like hell no it wasn't
antifa
it was me and i'm a trump supporter i
was there to support trump
[ __ ] break which leads me
which leads me sorry i'm getting a
little angry
this subject really hits hard it pisses
me off
that this what about ism because
that's the thing that's the thing if all
else fails
just blame black people if all else
fails just blame it on black people
let's talk part of trump's legal defense
here is not only to conflate
black lives matter with the [ __ ]
violent insurrection that these
treasonous
[ __ ] rained down on our country but the
blaming on black lives matter
you stupid [ __ ] it really should
not surprise me that i have to explain
this
to you dumb [ __ ] white
supremacist nazis
again a peaceful protest that is
designed to fight for the civil rights
of people
in this country is not the [ __ ] same
as an insurrection that is designed to
overthrow the constitution of the united
states
you dumb [ __ ] guess it really shouldn't
[ __ ] surprise me either
that you are the dumb [ __ ] that
not only do not understand the
constitution
you don't like the constitution you
don't want democracy
because democracy gives people rights
and you don't want that kind of [ __ ] do
you whitey
you [ __ ] nazi [ __ ] them
you goddamn right and that's what it is
it's a blame game
it's what about ism and it all plays
into this [ __ ] narrative that they
had at cpac
it's white grievance
that's what trump was about in the first
place that's why we had the election
that's why we had to go through four
years of this [ __ ] buffoon
is because they feel like something's
being taken away from them
take my country back it ain't your
country
it's everyone else's country too [ __ ]
and that's the narrative of this whole
god damn thing
his fear mongering that's why tom cotton
went on his tirade
about jihadis and ms-13
any any people of color that he could
point out
he was on it baby he was on it
by god if you got pigmentation in your
skin
you're to blame for the january
insurrection because
chuck grassley even said that if the
black lives matter weren't violent in
the summer there was no reason for white
people
to get violent as if as if
black people peacefully protesting for
civil rights in this country
is anywhere close to the same of a bunch
of toothless dumbass [ __ ] white
people
trying to overthrow the constitution
cause they didn't get their way
enough is enough of this [ __ ]
and we have to vote these people out
because they are going to try to
suppress our vote here folks that's
exactly what they're trying to do
with this blame game of its black lives
matter and antifa's fault
with this idea that that of the election
fraud we have to
we have to make sure our elections are
okay mike pence even wrote a [ __ ]
article he was the one that was gonna be
hanged
remember they had the gallows hang my
pens hang my pins
and he writes an op-ed saying yeah
there's election fraud hell yeah
and maybe the vice president should have
made trump the president what
come on that's what this is about this
isn't about trump 2024
and these people are going to be sadly
disappointed when he's not elected in
2024.
sadly disappointed
he's not running in 2024 [ __ ] at the end
of his speech he played around with it
so the q and honors could get on their
[ __ ] keyboards and start doing
equations and drawing lines here and
doing conspiracy theories here and
oh he said this code word me a [ __ ]
break
he's not running in 2024. i mean he's
gonna steal your money
trump supporters he's gonna take your
[ __ ] money
for sure he's totally gonna act like
he's running to take your [ __ ] money
so get your checkbook get your credit
card
let's do that
he ain't running this is all for voter
suppression
for the republican party to retain power
because without voter suppression they
can't retain
power because their [ __ ] ideas and
policies
[ __ ] suck and we know they do and
they know that we know
that their policies suck
and the thing they're scared of the most
is that 81 million
people are willing to vote against it
that's what they're scared of the most
is that 81 million people
are willing to vote against their
policies
that's the most important thing here so
keep on keep it on republicans
keep on keeping on and i think i think
the democrats
not only should they ram this
coronavirus
package down their throats now
there's a lot of debate about this 15 an
hour minimum wage and i really don't
have enough time
today to unpack
what the significance legislatively not
not
impact of the country because we
definitely know what the impact of the
country would be
if people had 15 hour minimum wage
we know what the impact would be we know
what the economic impact would be
we know it it's not rocket science we've
done it before
we've lifted the minimum wage before in
this country we've done that [ __ ]
we know what happens and we know that
there is a little bit of heartache in
the economy but overall that [ __ ] works
that [ __ ] works it causes more people to
have
more equity of the gdp which causes them
to spend
more money
which makes the engine of the economy
run better
but they don't give a [ __ ] about the
economy running better they care about
capturing the gdp
that's what they want they want their
percentage which is all of it
they want all of it
but the coronavirus package should be
rammed through we should get it through
into reconciliation
we should get it passed in the senate
this week with or without that 15
an hour minimum wage and i know a lot of
people are going to be pissed
oh you're abandoning the 15 an hour
minimum wage no
we don't need to abandon that we don't
have to abandon that issue
we can keep voting on that issue because
guys there's
one issue there's only one only one
issue that matters
in this country right now and democrats
and liberals and progressive and
moderates
and moderate republicans and never
trumpers
we need to be one issue voters one
one issue and one only end
the filibuster that's the nonsense
that's the [ __ ] that we're that
that's happening right now
in the filibuster you know they're
always one issue voters they want to
vote pro-life
or they want to vote oh i'm for lower
taxes
i'm for lower taxes that's why i vote
republican
which isn't even true in the slightest
so we need to be one-issue voters and if
you get anything from the podcast today
have you been listening
take that away from this to end voter
suppression
to get 15 an hour minimum wage to get
universal health care so people don't
have to go bankrupt
because they have a [ __ ] medical bill
we need to end the filibuster that is
the thing standing in the way of what
this country wants
as a majority minority rule is tearing
the country apart
and it's tearing their party apart
frankly
end the filibuster and we will end their
suppression
in the filibuster and you will get 15 an
hour minimum wage
in the filibuster and we will get
universal health care
a better system that is now whether it's
medicare for all whatever the [ __ ] we
want to hash out
we can hash that out when we get there
but a short term this week and next week
that coronavirus package
needs to be passed not only is it
important for every american to get
those stimulus checks to pump into the
economy
right right is right as the risk of
coronavirus is going to lift in the next
three or four months
as we reach some sort of herd immunity
only credit given to joe biden and his
team
to put together a hell of a lot [ __ ]
more infrastructure
and a hell of a lot more deals on this
vaccine than trump and his team would
ever [ __ ] dream of doing
the simple fact that joe biden his team
used a protection act that was signed
almost a year ago today
to get the merc johnson and johnson deal
to make sure that we pushed up herd
immunity
almost by four weeks
they are estimating we could reach herd
immunity sometime in may
if you remember just a few months ago
the same models the same models
were putting us in june and july
that is significant [ __ ] significant
so go get your [ __ ] vaccine go get it
let's end this [ __ ] let's end it
but let's not be [ __ ] dumb
let's not miss the point pass
the coveted relief bill so those
vaccines
can get into the arms of people
make sure that americans and small
business
and this country can get back on track
this summer it is time
it is time to put this trump virus in
the past
because that's what it is if we would
have had a government if we would have
had an acting president someone who got
up in the [ __ ] morning
and put his [ __ ] shoes on and went to
work
we wouldn't be in this [ __ ] mess but
he didn't
so we have to have another round of
coronavirus that's just what has to
happen
and we need to do it now with or without
the 15 dollar minimum wage
and if you want fifteen dollar minimum
wage if that's what you want
and you want universal health care and
you want a voting rights act
be a one issue voter whoever you're
voting for
whoever it is it doesn't matter if it's
dog catcher
or united states senator are you for
ending the filibuster
and if they say no you say who else
who else
filibuster filibuster filibuster in that
[ __ ]
teddy that's our one issue take that
from this podcast
take that and i appreciate you joining
me today we're winding down here on time
we're at about 53 minutes
i want to i want to talk to you about
one more thing that you guys might have
noticed in my videos
i got new hats they say [ __ ] them
that cool i love them so these are the
hats that i normally wear they're flex
fit hats
which i i really like flex fit hats they
fit my fat head good
uh they really you know fit it real nice
and nice and comfy
they're kind of warm but sometimes
that's good and
and they feel good backwards and
forwards right
you can wear it backwards you can wear
it for us and they're comfy
so these are going to be available soon
be watching out for that
but in the meantime if you want to
support the podcast
you can do a couple different things
number one watch the [ __ ]
youtube you can go to spotify you can
download on spotify
we are streaming on twitter last week
and this week
this week is the second week we've
streamed on twitter which is fantastic
i like that i like that we're streaming
on twitter
so go support this podcast by listening
to it or watching it
and then the other thing that you can do
is you can visit the merch store go to
thetonymichaels.com
click on the merch store get you a
t-shirt get you some sweatpants
get you a tank top get you a coffee mug
and by the way we have some really good
coffee mugs in there
they're [ __ ] trump coffee mugs
and these [ __ ] trump coffee mugs the
coffee oh my god
it tastes not taste so good inside one
of those cups
it says on the mug it says [ __ ] trump
and anyone who looks like
trump [ __ ] up and we also have it on a
sticker
and we have [ __ ] stickers we got
[ __ ] pillows
so if you're tired you want to lay down
but you're still a little angry about
what's going on
you can lay your head down on a [ __ ]
pillow so if you want to support the
podcast that would be fantastic
if you use the promotion code podcast so
just type in podcast for the promotion
code you get 10
off your order anything anything you
want in that merch store
you just type in the word [ __ ]
podcast you will get 10
off that whole goddamn order the
sweatpants the
t-shirt the hoodie the [ __ ] pillow
the whole nine yards
you'll get 10 percent off your order in
the merch store
so go check it out on the
tonymichaels.com just click on the merch
store
it'll take you right there you can look
at all the good stuff that's in there
and you'll have fun you'll have fun and
and be watching
be watching for the hats the hats are
going to be available soon they're not
in the merch store yet
but they're going to be available soon
so be keeping an eye out for that be
keeping an eye out
okay okay well i appreciate you guys
joining me this week
come come visit us next week i'm i want
to get a guest on
uh for next week to talk about the
vaccine someone who really actually
knows about the vaccine because i don't
know
anything but what i've read which i
don't understand it because it's a bunch
of science and
medical malarkey and i have no [ __ ]
idea what the [ __ ] any of it means
at all because i obviously am not
trained in those fields
now i try to read it the best i can and
take the advice the best i can
i definitely as soon as i'm offered uh
one of these vaccines i don't care if
it's the pfizer
i don't care if it's the the the moderna
the johnson johnson i don't even care if
viagra comes out with one in a pill form
and it gives you boners all day long i
will take the [ __ ] vaccine we need to
vaccinate
and wear your [ __ ] mask while you're
still out there texas
mississippi missouri all these states
that these bone-headed republican
governors
are lifting the the masked mandates and
and saying yeah coronavirus is gone
go have fun be courteous have some
[ __ ] manners for the next six or
eight weeks we're almost out of this
it's been a year you got six or eight
more weeks be [ __ ] patient here
do the right thing do the right thing
for your family for everyone else's
family
let's get this country back on track and
let's not kill anybody inadvertently
anymore
let's not do that thing for [ __ ] sake
i love you guys come back next week at
three o'clock watch me on twitter
stream it live on youtube or watch it
afterwards it's all up on youtube and
get caught up for crying out loud
go watch all the episodes we have we
have great episodes get caught up
and then we'll see you next week
wednesday three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern right here on the
tony michaels podcast
and if you aren't watching and those
people who don't want to watch
and don't like my material and don't
like the podcast
[ __ ] up
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me [ __ ]
them